up to 1 million Muslims remain in
detention in northwest China with no
access to legal help detained in
so-called vocational education centers
run by the Chinese government their
crime is their faith and the UN wants
this investigated for the second time in
six months UN Human Rights chief
Michelle bascially has asked China to
allow an independent assessment into its
detentions of Muslim minorities it's the
kind of appeal that could have come that
couldn't have come soon enough for Omar
bakkali
who was interned in one of these camps
the chains on Omar Batali's wrists
symbolize his imprisonment in a Chinese
reeducation camp the Kazakh Muslim was
tortured there for many months both
physically and psychologically in the
camp we had to learn communist party
songs by heart and perform them we had
to praise the party and say it's
everything to us
Chinese authorities accused Omar bakkali
of aiding terrorists he was arrested he
was housed together with around 40
people in one room at the camp his
cellmates included professors teachers
and doctors he speaks of systematic
punishment how did you manage horrible
amiss we were forced to eat pork if we
did not eat it if we did not praise the
party we were always punished Omer was
forced to stand for 18 hours he was
beaten after 8 months he was released
from the prison camp he believes it was
because he is a Kazakhstan national the
Chinese wanted him to keep quiet
many care I was allowed to leave the
camp on the condition that if I didn't
remain silent my family would pay for it
they were all sent to the prison camp
my father died there I don't know
anything about the fates of my mother
and my sister surveillance cameras a
watchtower razor wire this is what the
internment camps in Xinjiang looked like
from the outside they've existed since
2017 human rights activists as
there are up to a million prisoners
inside China denies that these are
re-education camps but human rights
activists and experts disagree and they
have satellite images that they say show
that these camps are being expanded and
joining me for more is dolkun isa he's
president of the world
Weger Congress and himself had to flee
China in the 90s to escape persecution
mr. Issa thank you very much for coming
to the studios at the outset I'd just
like to ask you the Chinese government
maintains that it runs vocational
training centers in shinjang and not
internment camps how do you react to
that well it is that I can say it is the
21st century concentration camp and the
China's Goldman even denied beginning of
the November any camps Chinese
government denied is if you don't have
any exist any camp but up to the grow up
International Treasury then and the
partly accept no it's saying yes we have
a camp but it is not concentration camp
or education camp that's just a
vocational camp or technical assistant
camp it is the Chinese government has
trying to hide in the reality now use
you called it the 21st century
concentration camps in he spoke of
international pressure do you think
there has been sufficient international
pressure brought to bear on the Chinese
government to close down these camps
well International Cooperation and just
some country particularly November of
November 6
during the UPR in China a lot of country
more than 14 country Rises camp issue
and ask the Chinese government shutdowns
this can and the Chinese government has
continually rejected it but it is did
their mind and the internationally to
Chinese government shut down this is the
reality and the Chinese go mad
continue expanded this camp well it is a
as we saw since a couple of months
Chinese government trying to hiding this
reality and continue expanding this camp
so but but these camps are still
expanding despite the international
pressure that you claim he's being
brought to bear
China what can be done to actually
prevent China from expanding these camps
well today's as we said in some
international pressure growing up some
countries spoke our own and asked the
Chinese government is a shot done but it
is not good enough just to consider the
issue just a reduced a Chinese
government it's not so my China's
government just a test in the world if
China internationally is some country
United Nations really some kick some
concrete action some sanctions was a
Chinese Goldman then it's useful then it
will be China's government and back
stepped and they will be closes camp as
we speak they're also reports that a
Kazakh activists Eric John balázs I
think you're aware of the work that he's
been carrying out he's been supporting
what working for kha'zix who have been
interned in these camps in Xinjiang he
has been arrested by the Kazakhstan
government why do you think that has
happened well it is the clear evidence
selection is a Kazakh nationality is he
is the Kazakh origin just his speak odd
and the Kazakh nationality who's in the
concentration camp the right and ask the
really is for this right for this the
Kazakhs people
she was arrested Kazakh government is a
day before yesterday before the last
week two weeks ago he was trying and he
has the page are on 600 the dollar fine
but yesterday he was they detain behind
all [ __ ] of course a pressure of the
Chinese government the Kazakhstan is the
Democrat country is mg of self should be
respect his freedom and expression he
didn't against any international law he
didn't against any Kazakhstan law just
he speak all the right of the Kazakh
people who is the concentration camp
very briefly towards the end as
president of the world weaker Congress
dolkun isa what would you like to say to
the international community what do they
need to do to have these camps closed
down in Xinjiang well you know after
Second World War and the world leader
gathering and the promise to the world
saying never again but today 21st
century is
again so it is the world has a good
experience a very bad experience on this
camp issue so that's why unity nation
international community particularly
Western country should be spoke loudly
and it should be take concrete action
and the moon should be and ask the
Chinese government and the sanction to
the Chinese government
then shutdowns can other way tomorrow to
be later to be too late tomorrow dolkun
isa president of the world we could
Congress thank you very much for coming
in and speaking to us I thank you so
much